it's not that it's but it's not that's
not the problem the problem is now
listen the maths is very simple you've
got people like Angie Tate talking about
these things with such Clarity and it
makes so much sense because it is true
right and then you have men that are in
these situations where just average
working an average job and they cannot
fulfill whatever definition is called to
be a man in these yes they can and
that's what they said he didn't say that
yes they can no a nine to five man can
do it but then again but wait wait this
is the thing what we're talking about as
a man and this is why I say it's very
important for us to understand the
person that we're speaking to and I'm
very glad that you clarified everything
that you mean not every man is like
Angie Tate not every man is going to be
able to even
realistically demand for certain things
from a woman so the same way women need
to compromise if he comes to a man who
is going to cheat on her because he's a
top G he's the same way men are gonna
have to compromise and stop now laughing
about purity